Technology giant IBM has created the tiniest film ever made,...
...which involved shifting the location of individual carbon atoms to create the movie's frames.
Guinness World Records has certified the 250-frame movie as the "Smallest Stop-Motion Film."
To make this movie, essentially what we did,...
...was we used a spectacularly sensitive type of microscope, the scanning tunneling microscope.
We literally moved individual atoms rapidly around the surface...
...and put them in one of the figures we wanted of a sequence,...
...and then took a picture of that.
We then moved them to a new position, took a picture of that,...
...and each new position was a little different than the previous.
That's how you make a movie a la the 1900s using technology a la the next century.
The entire film, titled "A Boy and His Atom,"...
...is made on a piece of material measuring only 45 by 25 nanometers.
Some ten million nanometers fit into a single centimeter.
In today's technology we've shrunken things so much, believe it or not,...
...at the level of the transistors and all the devices we care about in the world...
...as one example, we're down to the scale of atoms.
Some of these elements are so small, some of the parts of the transistors...
...and parts of technology, they're just atoms across.
We need to think about what are we going to do in ten years...
...when they become so small they no longer work.
With current technology shrinking at such a rapid pace,...
...it seems likely that the ability to move individual atoms in a precise manner...
...will become crucial for the future of electronics manufacturing.